if you drop a slinky dangling under its  own weight  the bottom won't start falling until the  whole slinky has collapsed  this is because each coil is stretched  to support the weight of everything  beneath it  so in order for one coil to fall it  needs the coil above it to collapse and  so on all the way up to the top  it's like a row of dominoes where the  tension released at the top  cascades down the slinky and this takes  some time  this is the longest slinky i had access  to and what's cool about this angle is  you can see the bottom starts to rotate  right there  meaning there is a twisting wave that  travels through the slinky faster than  the compression wave  the bottom is turning but still not  falling until the top  crashes into it